I think really if they were smart they
would go to Oakland I mean seriously I
mean what an entertainment value that
would be Antonio Brown Johnny Gruden
Paul Gunther Montez perfect I mean it's
been Cognito you've got to be crazy not
to go to Oakland I can't say enough
about Farrell and April what they've
done for us here in the last month
I think Jacobs is gonna be interesting
and fun to watch
who knows maybe hard-knocks will come
and cover that at the Austin brothers
before we found out that the Raiders
would be this year's team on Hardware
vests accom reported on Monday that the
NFL at the most recent owners meeting in
May discussed the possibility of changes
that could be made to Hard Knocks it's
such a strange exercise for the NFL
collectively the league loves it
individually the teams don't love it
they don't want to do it they're all for
it as long as somebody else gets to do
it and they constantly try to pass the
baton to someone else who saw the Gruden
brothers trying to do it there so Chris
today's draft yeah Hunt PFT life changes
we would like to see made to the Hard
Knocks series sure and I'd like to see
some changes made to the process for
deciding who gets first pick because you
always get it so go ahead well do you
want to call up today go ahead let's
call Tommy heads and it's still rigged
all right the change that I would make
without question and this doesn't
necessarily make it better but it makes
the process far more humane and it would
make more teams willing to do it I've
heard people like Bruce Arians rail
against this practice that there was a
time a few years ago where Roger Goodell
the NFL Commissioner said that the
league would like to look into more
humane ways of terminating the
employment of players one way to do that
would be to not televise it let's get
rid of all of them it's it's I I don't
like it and I know a lot of people do
and I know for some people it's like the
drawing car to the show to see when the
guy has to go in with his playbook and
sit down and be cut but how many
how many times do you need to see a guy
get cut to understand ok here's what
goes on when they go to get cut they get
told they don't have a job and they you
know they wish him the best and they say
something they don't mean about possibly
having an opportunity down the road
although every once in a while God does
have an opportunity down the road for
the most part he doesn't have an
opportunity down the road with that same
team we don't need to see that and from
my standpoint I don't know that the show
would be better yeah I'd be it would be
better
more compelling but I don't want that to
be what is compelling about it I don't
want to tune in to say oh I can't wait
to see who gets cut and how he reacts
we shouldn't be party to that and that
would definitely make the show better
because I think the league is better
than that than to show that week in and
week out throughout the course of hard
knocks yeah I mean I don't know if I
totally 100% agree with you I agree with
a lot of what you're saying I do think
it's overdone right it's certainly too
much I mean we show too much of it in
the conversations and listen I I get
this is you know everybody wants to see
how things work and you know how guys
can handle disappointment and all this
is your dream to play in the NFL and you
didn't get it night I understand that
gets people to turn in or tune in to
watch and all those things too but you
know I will also say you know hey
there's times where I do want to see
that conversation and even though yeah
it might not be cool to do to the player
and even the organization and it's a
tough spot I get you I don't want to see
it as much but I'll push back to you to
say I want to see it a little bit
especially if it's like a guy that's
like a true fringe guy or maybe a guy
that we didn't get expect to get cut to
me that makes good TV but I do think
it's a little annoying when we pray a
little bit on the lower roster guys all
the time and we show the disappointment
they constantly have to deal with but
Chris what would be more compelling yeah
seeing the meeting where the guy finds
out right is out of a job or maybe
seeing the meeting where the coaches
wrestle with that decision I think about
it for Mike to show that yeah I don't
know that we need to have one of the
worst moments of a guy's life right he
displayed on national TV I wouldn't want
it if it were me I mean you know what
everyone they did they did all or
nothing with the Rams the Amazon version
of Hard Knocks where they stay with the
team all season
right when it was time for Jeff Fischer
to get cut that meeting between him and
Kevin demo for staying Kroenke that was
not televised sure and I remember saying
at the time if it's good enough for the
players when they get fired during
training camp it should be good enough
for a coach who gets fired during the
regular season now though that Mike
those are those are all valid points and
again you know you're right I wouldn't
want them there either but that doesn't
mean it doesn't make for good TV I mean
it's a tough situation and everybody's
life so I hear you not a bad pick by you
my one the one I want to change right
off the bat is any team can be forced to
do hard knocks that would be my number
one thing you know first off okay I want
to see the better teams okay I do I mean
they're there they more times than not
have more of the star players more the
personalities you want have some more
interesting storylines now I know the
Raiders one is really good too but where
I would argue this to to me you know the
fact that like some of the lesser teams
in football always have to do this is a
disadvantage and going to keep them as
the lesser team I'd like to go back and
look at you know the success rate of
this team you know that of course is
towards the bottom of football because
the criteria of you know how you you
know so many years without the playoffs
and all those things that bounces you
into the Hard Knocks conversation I'd
like to see the records of these teams
and hard knocks because I can't think of
a whole lot of success stories coming
out of coming out of these things so
yeah I'd like to see the dynamic of
what's going on in New England or Kansas
City right now okay
or you know the New Orleans Saints oh
the Rams are the Bears or the KITT you
know the kicker things you know I think
we're missing a lot of storylines there
and I think it is a little unfair to the
lower teams that we put them at the
disadvantage of having to deal with one
of the biggest distractions you could
possibly deal with with getting ready to
the seat getting ready for the season we
know what I wasn't thinking of this but
you've given me an idea
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna include on the
fly make it about multiple teams okay
right why does it have to be one team
sure why can't it bounce around right
you figure out the top storylines going
into the season yeah and you assign the
NFL Films crews to those training camps
and you and you you do chunk of the show
each week to
to a different team and I think if you
do it right it could end up being very
very compelling especially if it's a
couple teams that will meet at some
point in joint practices meet in a
pre-season game I think that if you
don't restrict it to just one team you
can find a way to get the absolute best
moments from multiple different teams
every week that would make it a better
show because I think at times it drags
yeah yeah yeah there's only so much you
can tell me about what went on at
training camp in one week over the
course of an hour if you would if you
would have active storylines with
multiple different teams I think it
would make the show move faster you know
it's all part of one broader drama that
is the national football why should it
be just one team Thank You NFL you can
send me my check once you steal that
idea well I mean don't I get part of the
money too I mean you just piggyback you
improved my my idea I gave you the jump
off for your idea so I mean I almost
deserve credit for that pick to a degree
let's keep that in mind when we pick a
winner okay all right so that was your
second quick okay here's one that jumps
out to me here you know and a little
along the lines of what you just said
and that's what's things that you kind
of came up with it but this is a little
different I would actually like to see
that one of the at least one of the
preseason games I'd like to see the
other team that the team is you know if
Hard Knocks is following the Raiders I'd
like hard knocks to go to one of the
appreciation opponents too and have them
miked up not only for the game for which
they play each other but maybe for the
day or two you know in the preparation
to hear what that team is saying about
the other team or maybe how they
evaluate a player or as important as
importance to the offense or you know
during the preseason game if you have
the opponent team miked up they might
talk about all gosh they're they do
doing that play or you know when Antonio
Browns down to that position we got to
do this so that to me would lead some
cool context clues or just clues and
conversations about how other teams are
valuing or evaluating the team that
we're all watching which could you know
go off into better conversations as well
that would be one thing that I think
could be cool
there's so many it's funny just having
this draft having this association
reading it up creative juices yeah
blowing I mean I've got some ideas that
are popping into my head that I had not
thought about I'm from one for example
and you can steal this if you want for
your final pick how about just making it
for the full season why does it have to
just be training camp there or do all or
nothing that's all I see months after
the fact yeah just do an hour a week all
season long as long as the season lasts
right now again you the team's mate if
they don't want the disruption for
training camp they definitely don't want
the disruption all season long but at
some point your guys are gonna get used
to it but here's here's my third round
pick take away the ability of teams to
make edits right that no veto power you
know you can't say we're leaving that no
once you are the team right the cameras
are here the microphones are here and
we're not gonna sugarcoat it we're not
going to sanitize you know if it's
reality then let's have the full reality
as long as it's active although right
like not like not getting up like like
the plays or the audible that maybe Jon
Gruden wants to get yeah I mean
strategic information that affects game
day you that but but if it's
embarrassing right or if it's an awkward
moment well you know we don't want to
make the coach look bad we don't wanna
make the player look bad we don't want
to know you don't have the ability to
edit it and frankly I mean and I could
take this a step farther and say
somebody other than NFL Films should be
making these because there's still that
broader overriding desire to protect the
shield because NFL Films is the NFL if
you want a true documentary if you want
true reality have someone producer who's
got no connection whatsoever to the NFL
but that was too long of a of a topic
I'll just stick with no ability of the
teams to make any change well I mean
just that you're contradicting yourself
with your first pick in your third pick
there you know you're tough not a little
bit you don't want you know you don't
want to see people cut but yet here
we're talking about edits and they don't
want to edit that and they want to light
it in there I've no I'm not caught now
go ahead make it we're running out of
time make your third pick instead of
trying to crap all of us follow the
stars more okay I just don't care about
the number 87 the player on the roster
I'm sorry I know it's a cool story and
all that but at the end of the day damn
I'm tuning in because I
want to see Gruden Antonio Brown okay
maybe vantes Burfict and some other
stars along with that I want more on the
stars and then I want some of those big
personalities that are following around
I want them put together at like once a
week I want to be I want to have Gruden
Antonio Brown and Burfict
and incognito in the room to answer all
questions together so we see the
personalities bounce off each other too
so not only do we see them in their you
know singularity but we see them in a
group setting and see how crazy things
can get to so that would be one of mine
too
and I agree with you that element of
let's find a guy who's maybe gonna make
the roster maybe not and follow him that
that is played out I'm done but good in
2001 but let's give us access to the
star players the guys we care about that
we never see in this setting I agree
with you all right quick recap before we
take the break Chris Sims has any team
can be forced to participate follow a
pre-season opponent before the preseason
games and follow the Stars more I say no
televised cuts make the show about
multiple teams not just one and also no
ability by the teams involved to make
any edits to what gets shown other than
strategic information
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports